.
Ich fühle mich ein bisschen so,
als würde ich Brot
auf meinem Kopf backen.
No Poo - Haare waschen ohne Shampoo,
funktioniert das überhaupt?
Hallo, Freunde der Sonne,
ich bin's wieder, Mai,
eure Chemikerin des Vertrauens.
Heute mit dabei: Monster-Pickel.
Sieht man die?
Ich drehe mich einfach ein.
Ich heiße
euch willkommen zu einer Folge:
Nicht-Chemie chemisch erklärt,
oder so.
Ich meine, wollt ihr in eurem Alltag
Chemie reduzieren,
dann weiß ich zwar, was ihr meint...
# Ja, ich weiß, was du meinst
...nur dürft ihr nicht
immer alles Schlechte als Chemie
und alles Gute
als natürlich verstehen.
# Denn Darling, alles ist Chemie
Deswegen möchte heut was typisch
"Nicht-Chemisches", No Poo, nehmen
und es chemisch erklären.
No Poo oder No Shampoo ist der
Verzicht auf konventionelle Shampoos.
Ich erzähle euch kurz,
wie es dazu kam.
Denn die Hintergrundgeschichte
ist auch erzählenswert.
Während unserer "MaiLab"-Sommerpause
habe ich ein Selbst-Experiment
für "Quarks" gedreht.
Ich wollte Plastik
in einem Haushalt reduzieren.
Unter anderem wollte ich mein Shampoo
durch eine plastikfreie
Alternative ersetzen
und kam dabei auf diese Haarseife
aus dem Unverpackt-Laden.
Die Umstellung
fand ich relativ unproblematisch,
aber es geht deutlich spektakulärer.
Darf ich vorstellen: Shia,
Autorin, Bloggerin
und eine Zero-Waste-Queen.
Am 1. Tag meines "Quarks"-Experiments
besuchte sie mich zu Hause,
um sich
mein Plastik-Desaster anzuschauen
und mir ein
paar Start-Tipps zu geben.
Denn Shia und ihr Mann sind absolute
Pros darin, Müll zu vermeiden.
- Etwas nicht so Leckeres:
Das ist der Müll von 7 Monaten.
Müll, der wahrscheinlich
nicht recycelbar ist.
Von 2 Personen. Meinem Mann und mir.
Wenn ihr das
schon beeindruckend findet,
Freunde, hört euch an, wie Shia
sich seit Jahren die Haare wäscht.
Ich habe mir gut 3,5 Jahre lang
meine Haare
nur noch mit Roggenmehl gewaschen.
Falls ihr euch schon länger
mit No Poo befasst,
ist die Roggenmehl-Methode
vielleicht nichts Neues für euch,
aber für mich als 0815-Chemikerin
war das schon...
Der Gedanke früher,
den fand ich so ekelhaft.
Ich fand es so ekelhaft,
mir Mehl anzumischen.
Weil ich wusste,
meine Mutter macht Sauerteig.
Und Roggenmehl und Wasser
war ihr Sauerteigansatz.
Ich dachte, oh mein Gott,
sowas schmiere ich mir ins Haar.
Ich habe es eigentlich gemacht,
fast wie so ein Dare,
eine kleine Herausforderung
für mich,
dass ich mich selber überwinde
und Sachen außerhalb
meiner Comfort Zone mache.
Ich hab das wirklich gemacht
und war ziemlich begeistert.
Ich gebe zu, wenn ich
nicht live aus der Nähe
mit meinen eigenen Augen gesehen
hätte, wie schön Shias Haare sind,
wäre dieses Video
wohl nie entstanden.
Also habe ich mir Saadet geschnappt.
Saadet kennt ihr
entweder von "reporter",
wo sie vor vollem Körpereinsatz
nicht zurückschreckt,
oder von "MaiLab".
Hier ist sie
unter anderem selbsternannter...
- ...Depp für die Wissenschaft.
Ich war etwas misstrauisch,
als Mai mich anrief.
Mai hat angerufen und möchte
gerne probieren, wie es ist,
wenn man sich 10 Tage die Haare
ohne Shampoo wäscht,
hat aber natürlich keinen Bock,
es selber zu machen.
Deshalb muss das Versuchskaninchen
herhalten aka me.
Hab's aber trotzdem gemacht,
für die Wissenschaft.
Depp für die Wissenschaft.
Eine Sache ist noch ganz wichtig:
kein Vollkorn-Roggenmehl nehmen.
Oh nein!
* Alarm *
Die Schalen des vollen Korns
enthalten viele Ballaststoffe,
die sich nur sehr schwer
rauswaschen lassen.
Ich habe das ein paar ;al probiert
und ich krieg
das nicht rausgewaschen.
Man sieht danach aus,
als hätte man ganz schlimme Schuppen.
Ich habe das schlechte Gefühl,
dass meine Kopfhaut juckt.
Saadet kümmert sich also
um die Praxis, ich um die Theorie.
Juhu.
Ich bin für
die Arbeitsteilung ganz dankbar,
aber es gibt zu Roggenmehl-"Shampoo"
keinerlei
wissenschaftliche Literatur.
Aber was ich machen kann,
sind "educated guesses".
Ich kann also aus Sicht einer
Chemikerin schauen, was logisch ist.
Unter diesem Disclamer
gehen wir zur 1. Frage:
Was ist in Roggenmehl drin, das
eine reinigende Wirkung haben könnte?
Bei konventionellen Shampoos oder
auch meiner unverpackten Haarseife
dreht sich alles nur um eins:
um Tenside.
Zu Tensiden habe ich
schon einige Videos gemacht,
verlinke ich euch alles.
Kurz: Tenside bilden "Bizellen",
die Fett,
Talg und Schmutz einschließen.
So kann das Ganze
mit dem Wasser weggespült werden.
Ohne Tenside gibt es
nicht genügend Interaktion
zwischen dem Schmutz,
Fett und Wasser.
Stellt euch vor,
auf molekularer Ebene haben
die Wassermoleküle keine Möglichkeit,
den Schmutz oder das Fett
zu greifen und mitzuziehen.
Neben den Seifen, die man herstellt,
gibt es auch
natürlich vorkommende Tenside,
in der indischen Waschnuss,
der Rosskastanie und in Efeu
sind z.B. Saponine enthalten,
die man, genauso wie Seifen auch,
für's Waschen verwenden kann.
In Roggenmehl
sind aber keine Saponine
oder anderen
Tensid-artige Moleküle drin.
Wir haben also kein Tensid. Und
trotzdem funktioniert es irgendwie.
Ich muss gestehen, langsam
vertrau ich dem Ganzen irgendwie.
Darf ich die mal kurz anfassen?
Ich mein,
ich wasch meine Haare immer abends.
Jetzt ist quasi der 2. Morgen,
nachdem ich sie
das letzte Mal gewaschen hab,
und sie sehen voll normal aus.
Sie stehen ab wie immer,
das können sie gut,
aber sie sehen aus
wie mit normalem Shampoo.
Ich weiß nicht,
wie sich deine Haare sonst anfühlen,
aber fühlt sich gut an.
- Ja, etwas trocken in den Spitzen,
aber sie sehen nicht anders aus
als sonst. Verstrubbelt wie immer.
Roggenmehl besteht
zu 73% aus Kohlenhydraten,
genauer gesagt aus Stärke.
Und Stärke hat eine praktische
Eigenschaft für die Haarpflege:
Nämlich: Sie absorbiert Fett.
Deshalb wird Stärke auch
in Trockenshampoos eingesetzt.
Zudem hat Stärke
noch eine wichtige Eigenschaft:
Sie lässt sich mit Wasser mischen.
Sie löst sich zwar
nicht wie Salz oder Zucker,
aber im Gegensatz zu Öl
lässt sie sich wenigstens verteilen.
Das liegt am molekularen Aufbau
des Stärke-Moleküls.
Alle diese OH-Gruppen,
OH versteht sich immer super
mit H2O, dem Wasser-Molekül.
Stellt es euch so vor,
als könnten die Wasser-Moleküle
sich an diesen OH-Gruppen,
an dem Stärke-Molekül
festhalten und andersrum.
Wasserstoffbrücken-Bindungen
sagt man dazu.
Meine Theorie also:
Stärke absorbiert Fett und Schmutz.
Das Ganze wird Dank
Wasserstoffbrückenbindungen
vom Wasser weggewaschen.
Aber warum muss
man Roggenmehl nehmen?
Warum nimmt man nicht reine Stärke?
Ich nehme an, das ist alles
eine Frage der "Rheologie".
Zu rheologischen Eigenschaften
eines Materials
gehören Dinge wie
Verformbarkeit oder Fließverhalten.
Mischungen aus Stärke und Wasser
sind eines der beliebtesten
Vorführ-Experimente.
Handelt man die Mischung
langsam und vorsichtig,
ist sie relativ dünnflüssig.
Übt man aber
mit schnellen Bewegungen Druck aus,
erstarrt die Mischung.
Das ist zwar cool,
aber fürs Haarewaschen unpraktisch.
Entweder würde
die Sauce überall hinlaufen
oder es würde
beim Einmassieren lokal fest werden.
Mehl enthält neben Stärke auch
noch Proteine und Ballaststoffe,
die verhindern,
dass das Phänomen auftritt.
Mai,
was ich nicht alles tue für dich.
Gut, aber warum Roggenmehl?
Warum nicht Weizenmehl?
Das hat ja fast jeder,
Roggenmehl ist eher seltener.
Auch das erkläre ich mit Rheologie.
Weizenmehl enthält Gluten,
was ich hier schon mal erklärt hat:
Gluten setzt sich
zusammen aus 2 Proteinklassen,
den Gliadinen und den Gluteninen,
die erst zusammenfinden,
wenn man Wasser hinzugibt
und sich dann verbinden
und eine Art Kleber bilden.
Deswegen nennt man Gluten
auch das Kleber-Protein.
Es hält den Teig zusammen
und sorgt in Weißbrot
für die schöne Chewiness.
Roggenmehl enthält kein Gluten,
dafür mehr von "Pentosanen".
Pentosane sind Schleimstoffe.
Sie binden Wasser und sorgen
auch für einen gewissen Klebe-Effekt.
Durch die
unterschiedlichen Klebestoffe
haben Weizenmehl und Roggenmehl
auch verschiedene
rheologische Eigenschaften,
wenn man sie mit Wasser mischt.
Weizen-Teig, also Weizen und Wasser,
ist viskoelastisch.
Das bedeutet:
Wenn man den Teig dehnt,
zieht er sich wieder
in seine ursprüngliche Form zurück.
Roggenteig, also Roggen mit Wasser,
ist plastisch.
Wenn man den Teig
dehnt oder verformt, bleibt er so.
Das bedeutet: Roggenmehl-Teig
lässt sich leichter auf dem Kopf
verteilen als Weizenmehl-Teig.
Jetzt muss es quasi wie ganz
normales Shampoo reingerieben werden.
Gehört?
* Quietschen *
Also es ist wirklich sehr ungewohnt.
Es sieht merkwürdig aus.
Es ist irgendwie eine graue Masse,
die du vorher anrührst.
Und es fühlt sich
auch wirklich komisch an,
wenn du es in die Haare machst.
Es hat sich so trocken angefühlt
und auch irgendwie mehlig und teigig.
Natürlich,
du machst ja Mehl in deine Haare.
Ich fühle mich ein bisschen so,
als würde ich Brot
auf meinem Kopf backen.
Wer sich noch etwas gönnen möchte,
kann seine Hand anschließend
einer sauren Rinse unterziehen.
Ein Esslöffel Apfelessig,
300-500 ml Wasser.
So eine Mischung
hat einen pH-Wert um die 5.
Das ist im selben Bereich wie der
pH-Wert unserer Haut und Kopfhaut,
insofern alles gut.
Ich versuch mein Gesicht zu
schonen. Ich bin ne Essiggurke.
Naja, so schlimm ist es nicht,
nur ein leichter Nachgeschmack.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dass der Weichmach-Effekt
was damit zu tun hat,
dass ein tieferer pH-Wert
Kalk-Ablagerungen auflöst.
Das kennen wir auch vom Kalkreiniger.
Auch der ist leicht sauer.
Kaum hatte ich den es sich in den
Haaren, waren sie viel weicher.
Da war ich schon
ein bisschen positiver gestimmt.
Nach dem Duschen,
die riechen auch jetzt
schon gar nicht mehr nach Essig.
Ich hatte wirklich große Sorge,
dass es jemand merkt.
Ich musste direkt
arbeiten gehen am Tag danach
und saß 3 Tage in einem kleinen Raum
mit em Team zusammen. Ich dachte mir:
Boah, wenn ich jetzt nach Essig
stinke, fliege ich hochkant raus.
Aber es ist niemandem aufgefallen.
Ne Kollegin hat mich
sogar nach 'ner Woche gefragt:
Wann fängst du dein Haar-Experiment
an? Ich so: Bin fast fertig.
- Gutes Zeichen. - Ja. Es ist,
glaube ich, niemandem aufgefallen.
Sie riechen
nicht mehr so schön nach Shampoo.
Es riecht eigentlich noch nichts.
Es riecht sehr neutral.
Ich mag eigentlich
diesen Shampoo-Geruch. Das ist blöd.
- Aber die riechen
ja auch nicht schlecht. - Ne.
Willst du mal riechen?
- Ne. - Tu dir keinen Zwang an, Mai.
Man muss davon ausgehen, dass ein
konventionelles Shampoo mit Tensiden
Schmutz und Teig deutlich gründlicher
entfernt als ein Roggenmehl-Shampoo.
Allerdings wird der Talg nicht
zum Spaß produziert für unsere Haut,
sondern zum Schutz.
Auch Dermatologen raten davon ab,
täglich mit Seife zu duschen
oder sich die Haare zu waschen.
Nur die Hände sollte man sich
regelmäßig und gründlich
mit Seife waschen.
Roggenmehl-Shampoo funktioniert
und macht in der Theorie auch Sinn.
Als Fazit kann man festhalten:
Jeder, der Probleme
mit der Kopfhaut hat
oder weniger Plastik verbrauchen
möchte, kann das ausprobieren.
Es ist nicht schlimm,
auch wenn es sich schlimm anhört.
Ich bin ne Essiggurke.
Nur: Was mit dem Roggenmehl
in der Abflussleitung genau passiert,
das bleibt 'ne offene Frage.
Aber: Falls ihr Erfahrungen
mit No Poo habt, auch andere,
schreibt sie in die Kommentare.
Falls ihr andere "nicht-chemische"
Sachen für mich habt,
die ich chemisch
prüfen oder erklären kann,
schreibt sie in die Kommentare.
In der Endcard
hat Saadet noch etwas für euch:
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2018)
Ja. - Warte, noch eine Stufe stärker.
Jetzt musst du so deine Haare...
Wollen wir kurz 'nen Föhn holen?
Oh, sie holt 'nen Föhn.
Läuft die Kamera?
Ich bin jetzt mal die Stylistin.
In diese Richtung
und dabei so den Kopf schütteln.
Ich sehe nur Teile von dir,
aber ich versuch's.
Bist du bereit?
- Bereit. Gib's mir.
* Föhn dröhnt. *
* verführerische Musik *